NARRATOR: The
following content is
provided by MIT OpenCourseWare
under a Creative Commons
license.
Additional information
about our license
and MIT OpenCourseWare
in general
is available at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: So, you see that --
I thought maybe we've got enough
good examples in theory
where we need some practice.
We need some experiments with
some of the finite difference
methods that we've spoken about.
So I created this homework in
which you would like choose
one of these that we've done.
Well, actually, number two,
the Schrodinger equation,
which has that
imaginary i in there,
we haven't spoken
about yet, but you
could do the kind
of Fourier analysis
that we've done for
the heat equation.
But, of course, it's going to
be different because of that i.
You'll get an e to the minus
i k squared t, I guess.
And that means that's a
number of absolute value
1 instead of a rapidly
decaying coefficient.
OK, so my idea is to
choose one of those groups,
or a number five, if you want.
And say, by next
Friday, just give me
some experiment with a code.
In this case, you
could use -- well,
we have four methods and three
of them are already in code,
and you're welcome to
use those or your own.
And I raised
questions last time --
and I'll put this on the website
with a little more detail.
So just to give you an
idea of what's coming.
So this is the
problem that we're
in the middle of speaking
about, near the end,
the mixture of
convection and diffusion.
And this is Schrodinger,
which is new.
This is the advection equation,
or the one-way wave equation,
which we've started with,
and this is what's --
this'll be the subject of
today's lecture and next time.
And the best reference I can
give, as well as the textbook,
the applied math book has
significant discussion
of this conservation law.
But also it's very well
presented in the 16.920 lecture
notes that are on
OpenCourseWare,
lectures 11 and 12.
So I'm going to use those
as a guide in this lecture.
Anyway, I thought I'd
just put that up as, you
know, time to see what various
difference methods will do,
And again, it'll
be on the website.
OK.
Now to say another
word about this one,
this convection-diffusion
equation.
So, last time I wrote down a
difference equation very much
like that except what
I wrote down last time
was upwinded so that was just j.
Now it's j minus 1.
And the choice
there is not clear.
This gives us higher
accuracy, of course,
for that x difference,
because it's centered at j.
And we still have this
centered, of course.
The second difference
is centered.
So I wrote down here
what the coefficients
are of the three old values at j
plus 1, at j, and at j minus 1.
But there is one
important point here.
The price for that
extra accuracy
may possibly be a
negative coefficient.
This could be negative,
or it could be positive.
It depends which
is more important:
the small r, the convection
part, or the big R.
And let me follow up.
So you remember the price.
If we see a negative
coefficient,
then we expect some
oscillations to appear.
And actually, they were supposed
to appear in Figure 5.12,
but it hasn't been done yet.
And if you would choose
this one and do Figure 5.12,
I'll be incredibly grateful.
So Figure 5.12 was to show
the evolution from a u naught
for the convection-diffusion.
OK, so can I just -- do you see
that in comparing R with r over
2, those are dimensionless
quantities, right?
Can I take another
minute to try?
I'm a total amateur at
dimensional analysis.
I did always think, however,
that Einstein could have proved
-- well, not maybe proved, but
could have conjectured that E
was m c squared, the
most important equation
in relativity, just by
checking the dimensions.
I don't know if that
would -- I mean, right?
That would like -- might have
occurred to him to realize that
m c squared has the dimensions,
if we wrote those out,
of energy.
I don't know if that put an idea
into the system which produced,
of course, the fact
that -- and, of course,
there would be a
dimensionless constant,
which amazingly happens to be 1.
OK, so dimensional analysis
could, like, change the world.
This won't quite
change the world,
but a little touch of something.
OK, so can I just -- you
remember that this Peclet
number, and I'll write
his name down again.
P-E-C-L-E-T. The Peclet number.
In the differential
equation, the Peclet number
was a ratio, essentially
a ratio, of c to d.
But to get the -- I
think we needed --
was that what we needed?
We needed a length to
make it dimensionless.
c is the coefficient for -- c
over d sort of tells us roughly
the importance of
convection and diffusion,
but there's a length
scale to be included.
Now the cell Peclet number,
which I'll just call P,
I'm just going to
take to be r over R
because those are dimensionless.
And you see that it's
going to play a part here.
Let me see, I forgot.
I think I want r over R. Maybe
I want a 2 just because I would
like that to -- I'd like it
to come out simply there.
OK, so I may put in a 2.
So that r would be 2R*p.
Where did that 2 come
from, by the way?
Oh, I guess it came
from there, right?
It came from that minus 1/2.
So probably I want
a 2 there just so
that I have a very
simple decision
of whether this coefficient
is positive or negative, yeah.
So let me put in a 2.
OK, so r over 2 is R*P then.
This quantity is R times P,
so this is R minus R times P,
or it's R, which we know
is OK, times 1 minus P.
In other words, P smaller
than 1, that coefficient --
all the three
coefficients are positive.
It's certainly stable.
Not only stable,
it can't oscillate.
We can't have -- we're taking
a combination of the three old
values and oscillations
can't show up.
OK, so just to
see, what is this?
And you remember that r
is c delta t over delta x,
and capital R is d delta
t over delta x squared.
So just to complete this,
the delta t's cancel.
One of the delta x cancels.
The other one comes up.
So it's c over d, and then
we have a delta x and a 2.
So that's why it's called
the cell Peclet number,
because it's the cell
size, or in my convention,
half the cell size that gives
the length scale and decides
whether P is -- so I'm
just going to write down
the conclusion that
the figure should show.
P smaller than 1.
That means that this
coefficient is also positive.
So that's positive
coefficients, no oscillation.
And I think you'll see from
the output that P bigger than 1
produces oscillation
we don't like.
In other words, we really
don't want P larger than 1.
And of course you
could say, well,
look at P. It's got
a delta x in it.
That's not going
to be a big number.
And the method will work fine as
delta x and delta t go to zero,
but we're going to do
a finite calculation.
And so we're seeing
for the first time,
like, because we have two terms
that are not dimensionally
identical, c and d, that in that
competition between convection
and diffusion, the
length scale is crucial,
and the mesh size is crucial.
So I guess the answer
is we can resolve it
by taking delta x small
enough, and hopefully,
that's not a problem.
But, of course, you know that
there are many physical cases
in which the diffusion
coefficient or the viscosity
coefficient is small,
is quite small.
And so getting that
below 1 might be hard,
because this d could
be a very small number.
OK, so maybe -- can I
also mention on the --
as something that we
haven't done here,
was to move the second
derivative, this guy,
to time n plus 1,
make it implicit.
In the diffusion part,
one often does that.
The diffusion is
the term, is the one
that's forcing us to
take this coefficient R
below a half, delta
t of order delta
x squared, and the
way to avoid that is
to move the viscosity
term, at least half of it,
up to the new time.
OK, so that's a third method.
So we've done upwind last
time, centered, explicit
this time, but then
that's a third one that
has to be looked at.
OK, so that's where we
stand on linear problems.
I'm sort of ready to
jump into nonlinear ones,
recognizing that -- well,
there's always more to say
about linear ones.
What are some of the things that
we have not properly discussed?
Boundary conditions, above all.
Boundary conditions, and we
could do something with those,
and the notes will say more
about boundary conditions.
So there are several types
of boundary conditions.
I guess I'm going to say
something about them now,
but this'll be a board that
kind of gets covered up.
So boundary conditions: So
what are the different types?
Well, at a real
physical boundary,
we might have u equals 0.
Say, in heat flow, we
might hold the boundary --
it might be the edge of
a freezer or something --
we might hold the temperature
at zero, or at some given value.
We might prescribe
u at a boundary.
Or we might prescribe
the derivative.
And just in case we're
in several dimensions,
I'd better write it as
the outgoing derivative.
It could be prescribed, say, 0.
So what are those two types
of boundary conditions called?
One's called absorbing,
an absorbing boundary,
and the other is an
insulated boundary
where no heat goes through.
To maintain this, heat
probably does go through.
If our body is warm
and we're holding it
at zero on its boundary, then
heat is going to travel out.
And in fact, as time
goes to infinity,
we're going to approach
cold -- a uniformly cold.
Here, heat's not
allowed to travel out,
so what will happen
as time goes on
is it will approach a constant.
The temperature will approach a
constant because it can't leave
and it diffuses.
And now I wanted to
mention a third type
of boundary, which is a
purely computational boundary.
We talked last time
about Maxwell's equations
in free space, and
the big application
of Maxwell's equations, or one
of the big ones historically,
has been to, like, the
exterior of an airplane,
to radar, or other
electromagnetic signals.
So what do we do if we
have an exterior problem?
See, here, I was always thinking
about an interior problem.
You know, we're inside
0 to L or something.
But now, what do we do if
a region is the outside,
it's free space all the way?
Well, we have to create a
computational box of some sort.
So we create a box
in which we compute,
but the boundaries of this
box, the x-boundaries of it,
are purely artificial.
They're just because we
can't compute to infinity.
So waves travel in this box,
and they travel to the --
so you see what I mean?
We're solving it in all this
space, except that's too much,
so that's meant to be a very
large box, not a small one,
as large as we can afford.
But waves are still going to
hit the boundary of that box.
OK, what do we choose as
boundary condition there?
We don't want it to reflect
back because it's not
a real boundary.
So we have to create -- I'll
put ABC for absorbing boundary
condition.
Absorbing.
That A is for an absorbing
boundary condition.
And the creation of
these boundary conditions
is an important topic
within finite differences.
For Maxwell's
equations, a good idea
was produced and
keeps being developed,
called perfectly matched layer.
The idea in that
perfectly matched layer --
let me just write PML -- and
I haven't seen this so much
in other application areas.
The idea of this
perfectly matched layer
is to create an artificial
dielectric, I guess,
a dielectric medium it would
be, in the electromagnetic case.
An artificial thin layer, which
has just the right properties
to stop the wave and swallow it.
OK, I'll put on the
website references to that.
It's a bright idea,
but not totally simple,
and when we change difference
methods, then that perfectly
matched layer has to go with it.
OK, that's the
end of my thoughts
about linear problems for now.
We're coming back, of course,
in a few weeks to solving
large systems, large linear
systems, the kind that we would
meet if we use an
implicit method,
or the kind that
we meet if we're
solving a steady-state problem.
But for now, let me go
to that model equation.
And you see, right
away, the difference
between that equation and
the advection equation that
had a constant velocity.
Here we have of a velocity that
-- so c is minus u, I guess.
c is minus -- think of c -- this
u as being comparable to minus
c.
So, in other words,
if u is positive,
I'm now going to have
waves going to the right.
So let me just put this
down. u greater than 0
will mean waves going to
increasing x, to the right.
And the idea will be -- so we
have to discuss that problem.
And as always, we would like
to solve it analytically.
Find whatever formulas we can,
understand what's happening
in terms of these
characteristic lines, because --
when we have one equation
and one space variable,
we really can catch the
essence of the solution
by understanding the
characteristic lines.
And then how do we
do it numerically?
OK, before class, I wrote just
a few equivalent forms of it.
This is an equivalent form,
and this is, so to speak,
the right form.
This is the form where we
see a time derivative of u,
as always, and we see a space
derivative of u squared over 2,
which, of course, produces that.
But somehow this is the quantity
-- it's called the flux --
that's physically
meaningful, f of u.
So I've chosen a simple flux
function, u squared over 2.
So that's the
differential equation.
But you'll see that the
differential equation can
produce two solutions
at the same point,
and we have to choose.
In other words,
the differential --
the solution can
become discontinuous.
A perfectly smooth starting
function, after a while --
this is the essence
of the problem now.
I might have a smooth starting
function, at least continuous.
The solution is constant
along characteristic lines.
But what happens if two
characteristic lines
run into each other?
I've drawn that
possibility here.
And it'll take a little time to
see exactly what's happening,
but the characteristics
we can see here.
So the starting values
were 1 up to that point.
So when the starting
value is 1 and u
is constant along characteristic
lines, then u is 1,
and those lines, it's just
like having c equal to minus 1,
I guess, in the
one-way wave equation.
We have a one-way wave
going to the right
now along characteristic lines.
So u is 1 in this part
of the xt-plane, right?
We have to come
back to the formulas
to confirm what I just said.
And then, over here on the far
right, the starting value is 0,
and the characteristics
in that case,
the c associated with that
is 0, so it's a standing --
it's not moving.
The characteristics
are just straight lines
in the time direction.
Nothing's happening, right?
When you think of a
characteristic that's
going straight up, it's
just carrying the value of u
without moving left or
right, so u stays 0.
So u will be 1 here,
u will be 0 here,
and now something's
happening in here,
and we have to figure
out what it is.
But maybe I can anticipate the
main point before any algebra.
The characteristic
lines in this region
have a slope somewhere between
the slope 1 and the slope 0.
You see, we're starting
-- let me graph u_0 of x.
So let me graph. u_0 of x is
-- the key points are 0 and 1,
0 and 1.
So u_0 of x, I start with a
constant initial function,
a constant profile to the left
of 0, and a constant profile
to the right of 1,
and linear between.
OK, so it's that starting
values that I wrote here:
1, 1 minus x, and 0
are these three pieces.
And then here I'm
in the xt-plane
where here I'm in the xu-plane.
So I drew characteristics,
and we still have to track --
we have to say more
what characteristics are
and understand that these
have slopes in between,
but you're not surprised because
the values of u are in between
1 and 0.
So they go that way
and they meet here.
So up to time t equal
1, characteristics
tell everything.
Up to t equal 1,
I know that u will
be 1 along these
characteristics,
and when I find these
u is whatever it starts at.
And u is 0 up all of
these characteristics,
so up to that time,
the algebra --
the differential equation
is going to be totally OK.
But after that time, the
differential equation
is in difficulty.
Because at that moment t -- so
what's happening as t increases
from 0 to 1?
This is the picture
at t equals 0.
The picture at t equal to 1
-- t equal to half, let's say.
What would be the picture
at t equal to half?
Well, at t equal to
half, this state 1,
has penetrated
this far, halfway.
Then, in here is this
converging characteristic that
come from a linear profile.
And over here, it's all zeros.
So that zero is still there,
but -- you see what's happening?
This guy is -- the
profile is steepening.
This is at t equal to half.
Steeper.
We still have the
algebra to do, but I
think the first thing is to
see roughly what's happening.
Then at t equal to 1,
this is totally steep.
So this is the situation
at t equal to 1.
And I could've given you that
as the initial condition,
but I and the 16.920
notes, thought, OK,
let's have a little
peace for awhile,
see what those
characteristics are doing when
they're converging, but
they're not crossing.
The trouble is, after t equal
to 1, they are crossing.
And now, what's the solution
in this crosshatched region?
Do I take the value
of 0 that's coming up
along these characteristics?
Do I take the value
1 that's coming
along these characteristics?
What's happening in here?
So there's a crosshatched
region there,
which is a big question
mark because my rule
of following characteristics
has led me to two answers.
And we want a physically
relevant answer.
We're sort of
expecting, and we'll
see, that this step
function is a step function.
I mean, the answer will
be a step function.
It will be 1 and then
drop to 0 along some path
in the xt-plane, which
is not a characteristic.
The characteristics are going
at 45 degrees and at 90 degrees.
And actually, so this is the
region I'm interested in.
So can I blow up that region?
So if I blow up that region,
that's where the shocks --
the shocks are meeting
everywhere in this region.
This was the point --
what was that point?
I guess that was the point
x equals 0 and t equal to 1,
there.
OK, and the question is -- and
I know that I have u equals 0
over here, and I know --
oops, u equal 1 over here,
and I know that I
have u equal 0 here,
but the question is
where, and -- well,
what happens in between?
You can think of at least
two possible scenarios,
and one of those is that
there's a shock line that goes,
let's say, somewhere
in the middle.
And so u stays 1 all
the way to that line
and drops to 0 after it.
In other words, this wall of
water travels to the right.
The shock, the
discontinuity, moves along,
not necessarily at the
speed that this one --
this would be moving along the
speed of 1, with this pushing.
Not stationary either, which
is what this right side would
like, but somewhere between.
So that's a shock line.
I'll just, for short,
call it a shock.
Then there's
another possibility.
And that will happen
in this case, actually.
That will happen in this case.
But there is another
possibility that
will happen in other
cases, and that would
be a fan of characteristics.
Let me see that when it comes,
but I'm just mentioning it
to say that this business
of the shock line,
which is what we'll
pursue now, which --
because it's what happens
with this problem --
is not the only -- is not
always the way to match,
the way to deal with a problem
of lack of information coming
from the characteristics.
OK, so I guess our question
is, what is that shock line?
What's the path?
What's the slope,
and what controls it?
And the answer will be
that what controls --
we run into problems with
the differential equations.
And the way to see what
continues to happen
is to go to the integrated
form, the integral form
of the equation, where, of
course, by taking an integral,
I make everything
smoother, and also I
preserve the physical
law, the conservation law.
So this is really
the conservation law.
What is this?
Well, let's first of all
see where it comes from.
It just comes from integrating
this equation with respect
to x.
So I have a time derivative
that I keep out here,
but my space derivative is
going to disappear because I'm
integrating with respect to x.
So I can call d by dt or partial
d by dt the integral of u with
respect to x, and I'm
integrating from somewhere --
from some point to
some other point.
Instead of a and b, I'll call
them -- I really should --
I'm sorry, I should say x on
the left and x on the right.
Some point x at the left and
some point x at the right.
And now I've
integrated this one.
I've called -- this is f of u
so I'm now thinking of any flux
function.
And the integral,
of course, gives me
f of u at the upper end minus
f of u at the lower end.
OK, so that's the
conservation law.
Let me write that word down.
This is the conservation law.
What is it saying?
It's saying that the change in
the quantity in the integral is
given by -- if there's any
change, any time derivative,
the rate of change
in the interval --
it's the conservation
of this integral,
meaning that any change in that
integral happens because there
is flow going out the
right-hand side of the interval
or there's flow coming in the
left side of the interval.
So that's why we have a
minus sign between them.
So that's a statement of
conservation, and -- oh,
there's one more example
that I'll mention now.
Let me give this
particular equation a name,
just because you see it.
You often see it written --
called Burger's equation.
But actually, the full name
is the inviscid, no viscosity,
Burgers' equation
because it's a 0.
So just one word about
Burger's equation.
So Burger allowed
a u_xx term here.
So he had one of our
-- nonlinear convection
and a diffusion term, and his
convection was this simple
expression u*u_x.
It's the kind of thing you see
in the Navier-Stokes equations,
right?
The nonlinearity
in Navier-Stokes
is sort of in this term,
of this general sort,
but this is a major
simplification.
Such a simplification
that Burger could solve,
even though the
equation was nonlinear.
Well, two people,
at the same time,
discovered the
change of variable,
a simple little trick.
Hopf and Cole.
I'll put their names
down because they
had nice, short last names.
They both discovered -- in
the case of a diffusion term,
they both discovered a little --
a change of variables that made
the equation linear.
Then they could
solve the equation.
That's in the textbook in the
section on conservation laws.
And then the important
thing that Burger could do
was let the diffusion
coefficient go to zero.
So then in the limit, he got
the inviscid Burger's equation,
the one we're looking at.
And he could look
at the solution
and let the limit go to zero.
And that's another way to figure
out what's the right solution.
That's the viscosity method,
a fundamental method,
for finding out when we
run into a problem, shocks
run into each other.
We don't know what to choose.
One way to find out,
in this 1D problem
and also in much tougher
nonlinear multidimensional
problems, is put a
little viscosity in,
and let it be small.
Let it even get smaller.
Then -- with a little viscosity,
officially this term --
in some sense, this term,
because it's a second
derivative, is officially,
mathematically speaking,
sort of dominates this
one as far as -- I mean,
this will produce
a smooth solution.
This term, as we know
doesn't smooth the solution.
It just advects it,
just carries it along.
But this term will smooth it.
So this is the dominant
term, the second derivative.
No surprise.
So when we introduce that,
that smooths everything.
We have no problem to say
there is a solution, at least
for simpler models,
and then we can
see what happens when
that term approaches zero.
OK, so that's another method.
And, of course, that's
kind of what we're
doing with finite differences.
Finite differences, if we
put in a little viscosity,
a little second-space
difference,
and take delta t small
enough for stability,
then we can solve it.
And if we take it very small,
we should get something close
to the inviscid limit.
OK, I was just
giving Burger's name
to that particular example.
So this isn't the only example,
but it's the simplest example.
OK, another example
of conservation laws
that everybody likes, I
think, is the traffic flow,
traffic flow in one
direction, say, on the Mass.
Pike.
So what's the equation
of traffic flow?
Let me put that on a
board here, and then I
have to come back to this.
Well, I'll put it here.
So Example 2 -- well, I don't
know if you can call that
Example 1.
We didn't give it
a physical meaning.
Example 2 will be traffic flow
in 1D, and what's the unknown?
Well, it's the thing
I've been calling u,
but for traffic flow,
the natural unknown
is the density of the traffic,
the density of the cars.
And everybody uses
rho for density.
So can I use rho rather than u?
And then, in the
equation will be a car --
a velocity that I'll call
v. That's not a new unknown.
In fact, the velocity
experimentally depends -- oh,
there's a relation.
The density and velocity
are, by experiments,
if you run an
experiment on the Mass.
Pike in heavy traffic -- that
could be a homework problem,
too -- to find the
relation between v and rho.
So I'm going to keep
this rho as the unknown
and imagine that we have some
experimental velocity v of rho.
And what would we expect?
I guess we expect that
as rho increases --
as the density increases,
what will happen?
As the density increases, the
traffic is going to slow down,
ultimately come to a stop, where
if the density is very small,
so the density 0 -- I mean,
we just have a single driver,
the police are not out, so
he's going v_max or 2*v_max.
But as the road gets
crowded, the velocity
drops and maybe drops linearly.
That would be a possible
and not that terrible
relation between v and rho.
So what would be the flux
function in this traffic flow
problem?
The conservation law is like
conservation of cars, right?
If we look at a unit, a
piece of the turnpike, then
the conservation law says
that the total number
of cars inside, which is
this, changes by cars leaving
and by cars entering.
And so the flux function
I think will be --
so we have to know like sort
of how many cars are leaving,
and I think the flux function
would be probably v times rho.
I think the flux function of
-- rho, now, is my unknown --
I think would be v
of rho times rho,
the velocity times the density.
That tells me how many
cars are going out.
OK, so I guess what I want to
say is that we will meet --
that we meet, in this
traffic flow example,
exactly these
possibilities that --
we meet them mathematically just
the way we meet them in actual
driving -- of a shock.
So this shock corresponds
to -- so what that's?
Like stop-go -- this
corresponds to, I suppose,
like meeting a red light?
Coming up to a red light, the
traffic you're behind normally
stops.
It has to slow
way down and stop.
Then the light turns green.
The first car takes off.
The cars begin to spread out.
That's the solution
that I don't see
with this starting function,
a sort of fan of cars.
So maybe I could write those
words down: shock or a fan.
The shock is what happens when
characteristics come together,
cars come together.
The fan is when the
characteristics fan out.
Actually, I could illustrate
a fan here right away.
Suppose I reverse 0 and
1 just to see what -- OK,
so here's my --
this is my x again.
So here I'm going to have u_0
to be 0 now, u_0 to be -- well,
I can even -- it's called a
Riemann problem when there are
just two values here.
u_0 is 1.
So the so-called Riemann
problem is the cleanest example
of the whole
conservation law theory
when there are just two starting
values, 0 and 1, or 1 and 0.
And it makes a big difference.
1 and 0, we saw when we reached
time 1, we had a 1 and a 0,
and after that, a shock formed.
Here 0 and 1, the
characteristics
here are going as always.
So u is 1 here.
The characteristics here,
this is staying at 0.
There's no reason to change.
But here we have now a region,
just like the other one,
but with a major difference.
That now, it's 0
on the left and 1
on the right, where before,
it was 1 on the left
and 0 on the right.
And the question is,
what happens in here?
Well, you might think
a shock, a step up
from 0 to 1 at some point.
And I would have to agree that
you could do that in such a way
that you maintained
the conservation law.
But that's not what happens.
This is going to
be a fan in here.
We're going to have -- what
we'll have is characteristics
in here.
This will -- let me
draw the profile.
So the profile is 0
there to 0 at some time.
Then over here, where this
characteristic is met, it's 1,
and this is what
happens: Instead
of getting worse, less
smooth, the solution
gets better, more smooth, when
the direction is reversed.
So we see that our problem
had to be nonlinear.
A linear problem couldn't
do these two opposite things
in the same thing.
So here we would have a fan and
the characteristics go there,
and it's reflected there.
OK, so there's a picture of the
phenomena that we're looking at
and we would like to
see numerically, too.
So next time I want to find --
so I can say now what I have
to do next time.
One is to locate the shock, the
shock line, when there is one,
and two, to decide -- how do
we decide between shock or fan
when from the point of
view of pure conservation,
we could choose.
But nature makes a choice.
And one way to decide,
make that decision,
is Burger's way of putting
in a little diffusion
and letting it disappear,
but we need a direct rule.
So we need a direct
entropy condition.
So this is going to
be a shock speed --
a formula for shock speed s
-- s equals shock speed --
we'll find, if there is a shock.
And number two is going to be
-- this decision is going to be
based on a quantity
called entropy,
which appears only in
nonlinear problems, really.
OK, so that's a
beginning picture,
which these 16.920 notes
are an excellent reference
for, the book also.
And Monday's lecture
will pick up there.
So we can see the
two situations here,
and the question is what
do we do at this point.
OK, see you Monday.
Have a good weekend.
And any email questions
about the homework,
just you could send to me or --
and/or to -- maybe and to Mr.
Cho, who will be looking at
the homeworks that come in.
Good, thanks.